the same time with one chance program so
this is online and matching based market
design it's a program that's going to
involve theoretical computer scientists
economists and operations research folks
and it's another experimental one in the
sense that we're running a shorter
format program it's it's running for
only six weeks with the hope of being
able to involve in an intensive and
ongoing way this particularly the
economist
okay okay so that's the program online
and matching based market design and fly
organizers it I is an Operations
research person Federico is the fabulous
economist Nicole actually there are six
organizers because Nicole is computer
science person but she always amazes me
how much economics she knows
so I counted as both honestly she's not
as much as Federico and Liat combined
honestly I know a thing or two about
algorithmic part of it and economics but
I'm mainly an algorithms person and Liat
is a fabulous economist who just left
defected from Caltech to Princeton this
is a big chair anyway so that's the pimp
and and yeah behind the scenes al Roth
will be a big supporter of this program
we'll talk about a lot in a minute but
here are the kinds of markets that came
about as our all our lives moved on to
online platforms you know the internet
and mobile computing based platforms and
they are they are not just ordinary
markets that just got ported to the
Internet these are new markets with
amazingly new ideas and because there
are new markets there are new ways of
providing them and there are new
questions altogether of an economic and
algorithmic type that arise and in fact
if you look at the sum total of all the
all the I don't know the revenue or
whatever the involvement of these
markets in the in the economy it's a
substantial fraction which keeps growing
every year
and that's the amazing part and and
there's no end to it obviously so one
thing I should note here is that many of
these markets are matching based like
here you want to match queries to
advertisers
here you want to match customers to cars
here you want to match customers to
rooms these are where you want to match
workforce to people all hiring here you
want to really match a man and a woman
okay and so on so so what has this to do
with the online platforms matching it
should be ancient right it is so the
first matching based markets were
designed in 1920s pre-internet and
pre-computer allocating hospital
residents in some hanky-panky way but
which actually turned out to be some
aspect of stable matching and then in
the 60s Gale and Shapley gave their
fabulous algorithm which made you know
huge progress on this front and then
there were many more matching based
markets that came about like kidney
exchange school choice which is being
run all over in big cities like New York
and Boston and eventually in 2012 Elrod
and Lloyd shapely got the Nobel in
economics Gail was had already passed
away and that was the topic of their
there I mean that was the the reason for
their Nobel Prize and as I said Al Roth
will be playing a substantial role in
this program he is that Stanford and
he'll come across often he told me okay
so so what this program is about is not
only the online ones but also the
matching ones you know I just combined
the two lists and and these markets use
methodology from two disciplines one of
course is economics which has been
studying markets for the last 250 or
years ever since Adam Smith 1976 Wealth
of Nations and us who developed this
very powerful algorithmic way of
thinking which we believe will
revolutionize will be sort of the like
the mathematics the rule that
mathematics played as a key enabler of
scientists in the last
century we believe algorithms will play
in this century and it it it's already
becoming evident that this is a true
statement let's hope it becomes even
more true and and of course we have
given very powerful algorithms like the
stable matching algorithm maximum
matching algorithms that go to design
kidney exchange markets budget
allocation algorithms that go for to do
AdWords problems and so on so so the
amazing thing the new thing about this
program is that it's only six weeks long
because because economists know the
value of their time and they cannot just
hang around and and so this is for the
first time we are going to bring
together these two peoples under the
same roof namely this one for an
extended period of time namely six weeks
so far they only met our coffee at easy
if if at all okay and then one outcome
of this is a book on market design
that's been put together by three people
three of the organizers of that year or
program there will be 30 plus
contributed chapters with the foreword
by Al Roth and it's going to be in
Cambridge University space ok so the
last two minutes I want to give you a
small case study why do you tell you
about one market about which I know a
few things just to tell you how
influential these markets are these
online markets and I'll assume that this
company is common knowledge among
industry and and university people and
in fact this this company has absolutely
transformed our lives think about it how
the people here are probably on Google
right now
okay and it went public in 2004 with a
market valuation of thirty to twenty
three billion which was considered too
high at this point Google brings us
search for free it's a happy to
transform our lives for free okay yeah I
see that yeah me no it's not free now
but it's nobody put charges $9.99 per
month or refer to reuse Google right and
and and there is what is what is paying
for this mark this this free free
service that they are bringing us well
if Google's AdWords market which almost
single-handedly supports the entire
multi-billion dollar operation as well
as for whoever has talked in Google
today here the seven hundred and eighty
billion dollar valuation that this
market has so you can imagine how big
the AdWords market is it is a gigantic
okay it's a gigantic huge market and the
amazing thing is that our field has
played a key role here in particular
algorithms have key player killed over
here algorithms of course I've played a
key role in search you know think of
PageRank
but here there was a problem with that
came up in 2004 namely these these
keywords were just being auctioned off
to the highest bidder and that was not
the correct way to do things because
because the bidders also declared a
daily budget and if you don't take that
into consideration the whole thing is
hanky panky goes haywire and you have to
take it into consideration because
because the there's a very heavy tail in
the in the way people participate you
know the small small budget people make
up a huge fraction of the revenue of
Google and so we came across this
problem in 2004 through Monica hands
Inger who was working in Google and
Aaron neck Mehta who's here the Google
representative and our representative
here we gave a very simple algorithm
online
optimal online algorithm for budget
adoptions and it's widely used by just
about every search engine company
including Google the amazing thing
probably keep saying amazing because it
gets more and more amazing but this time
it's really amazing the solution has its
roots in pure theory in matching theory
ok in 1990 big carpools here in the
audience and Oh Mitch was Ronnie who
came and left probably he told me on the
phone anyway we gave this online
bipartite matching algorithm also
optimal and the Google problem is a
generalization of this in some ways and
the restriction in some ways and this
was another very fine piece of work of
which also the Google problem is a
generalization this is online be
matching ok I'm done with all my amazing
things any questions so they'll be
industry participation arenas will be
there Nikhil Devon Road will be there
many people from uber will be there and
and I wanted to wish till the industry
people here if they want to come in I'm
not sure I have floated that idea to
people because everybody talks about
data science and if you don't link
yourself to data science you're missing
out right so I think we will eventually
put that angle in so yes oh great
any kind of matching activity I think
has an optimization there's an
optimization thing for efficiency behind
it
do people in this yeah think about all
the time yeah so so in in this you're
optimizing the number of people who got
married this is a sort of more this is
just how should I say it
this is monogamous marriage is this
polygamous marriage and here also you're
optimizing the number of marriages that
happened yeah
for example is there a lot of thought
given to whether or not things like
optimizing you know quote social welfare
which is like the sum of utility all the
time why do you think the economist will
be here yeah so so so when we talk about
maximum matching when you when you are
doing kidney exchange and you are using
maximum matching
yeah so here so that's that's an
optimization you're finding the maximum
matching in stable matching you're
finding a stable matching there's no
optimization but because there's always
a stable matching in budgeted allocation
again you're maximizing Google's revenue
so in all these matching problems you
are maximizing it's an optimization
issue yes is the global maximization the
best thing to do Google's revenue is
being optimized for his sake and here
for the sake of the the sick people the
number of kidneys that are exchanged is
being maximized and here sometimes there
is an optimization it's a number of
people who get to their first ranked
schools when you're doing school choice
or or the number of people who get
Hospital interns will go to their first
ranked hospitals that's being maximized
so there are you know definitely that's
a big part of the whole issue thank you
so much
[Applause]